- Якщо порівнювати мою сьогоднішню роботу
з тим, як працював мій дід, то це небо і земля.
Зараз машини їздять частково автономно.
Фермер має бути готовим до нових технологій,
розумітися на них і хотіти їх освоїти.
Цей фермер - водночас інженер та експерт
із програмного забезпечення. Він допомагає
створити мережу великих сільськогосподарських машин,
які мають збирати та оцінювати дані,
робити аналіз того,
як фермери можуть  найбільш ефективно використовувати насіння,
добрива та інвестиції. Це -  новий напрям
для виробників сільськогосподарської техніки.
- Ми маємо колись нагодувати 9 або 10 мільйонів людей,
але це не спрацює, якщо врожайність
та ефективність залишатимуться на теперішньому рівні.
Треба і використовувати ресурси більш раціонально.
Де теорія, там і практика. Приміром, дослідження
витрат палива проводяться на фермі, де Кай Aнке
колись вчився фермерству.
Уся його техніка під'єднана до інтернету.
Робота водія стає технічно складнішою.
Ось цю лінію руху я запрограмував сам.
Водій їде в машині, проте не має нею керувати.
Супутникові карти допомагають не збитися зі шляху
ані на сантиметр. Причому керівництво,
сидячи в офісі,  може спостерігати за процесом
і бачить кожну помилку.
Багато чого оснащують новими технологіями у хліву.
Це підвищує прибутки.
Процес годування вже давно автоматизований
Утім, хоч раз на день фермер
таки має заглядати у хлів, каже Анке.
Та чи дійсно це робить кожен,  якщо
комп’ютер запускає годувальницю самостійно?
- Зараз у нас дві тисячі свиней, і годувати їх вручну
абсолютно неможливо. Тому дуже добре, що в нас є
повністю автоматичне годування свиней.
Коли Лукас фон Макензен свистить, це означає, що час їсти.
Він, як у старі добрі часи, розкладає сіно вилами.
У його родині переконані: місця новим технологіям у хліву немає.
- Тут є беззаперечна перевага: я бачу своїх тварин і чую їх.
За криком вівці або ягняти можна розпізнати,
чи болить у них щось, чи шукає вівця своє дитинча,
чи навпаки - ягня загубило маму. Насправді
можна зрозуміти все, що відбувається.
А ось у мене є автоматизоване годування
я вдома натиснув на кнопку, бачу на екрані,
що всі їдять, але нічого не чую.
- Мені подобається, коли тварини йдуть з тобою на контакт.
Бо у них спілкування не лише через зір.  Вони нюхають, торкаються тебе.
- То камери у хліві недостатньо
- Ні, в жодному разі!
Утім, за межами хліву нові технології
таки спрощують їхню роботу.
- Сьогодні в нас є смартфони. Можна
вдягтися на гамак,
написати е-мейли, почитати в інтернеті про вівчарство.
Можна робити все.
Повертаємося до морквяного поля.
Посіви тут поки що прополюють від бур’янів вручну.
Але щонайменше в екологічно чистий спосіб:
ця машина рухається завдяки сонячній батареї на даху.
Однак робітників, які зриватимуть бур’яни
по вісім годин на день, знайти непросто.
Коли можна буде автоматизувати цю роботу?
Прогрес у цьому питанні, на думку фермерів,
недостатньо швидкий.
- Ми бачимо, що в довготривалій перспективі
у нас цієї робочої сили більше не буде.
Тому нам потрібні технології, які  допоможуть боротися з бур’янами.
Такі технології в Німеччині вже випробовують.
Це - "аграрний андроїд", який може самостійно визначати
та знищувати бур'ян без хімікатів.
Тому продукція буде органічною.
Однак і такі андроїди на полях - ще не межа.
- Ми мріємо, що колись можна буде їхати по полю
з маленьким причепом, відкрити люк, а звідти
вилетять 100 дронів і зроблять усе, що треба, самі.
Коли дрони переймуть важку працю людей на полях,
як зміниться сільське господарство, наше харчування
та поводження з тваринами? Усе залежатиме
від нових технологій і того, як ми їх використовуємо.